قال رئيس الوزراء الياباني بلاده ستقود
الجهود في قمه مجموعه السبع القادمه
للوصول الى عالم خال من الاسلحه النوويه
وقال كشد في خطاب امام البرلمان ان تطوير
كوريا الشماليه صواريخ نوويه هو انتهاك
للقانون الدولي وتهديد لامني وسلام
المنطقه مضيفا ان اليابان ستعمل بجد لضمان
ان تكون منطقه المحيطين الهندي حره
ومفتوحه امام الملاحه الدوليه
معنى الان من طوكيو مراسل الجزيره فادي
سلامه فادي ماذا في تفاصيل هذا الخطاب
لرئيس الوزراء الياباني
ات الحاليه في هذا العام وهي تستمر
الى قضايا محليه تتعلق بالوضع الاقتصاديه
في اليابان وتراجع عدد السكان ولكن ابرز
ما جاء في خطابته
المنحه التي ستنتقده الحكومه اليابانيه
بوضعها في ما يتعلق ايضا بمحاوله اتخاذها
موقفه قياديا لحل المشاكل المتعلقه رئيس
الوزراء تتحدث عن ان البيئه الامنيه
المحيطه باليابان اصبحت الان في عقد اصعب
مستوى منذ نهايه الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وحدد نقاطا سيكون طرحها في القمه مجموعه
السبعه التي تستضيفها اليابان في مدينه
هيروشيما ما يغير القادم
من ابرز ما ذكره في هذا الخطاب كان الحديث
عن ان اليمن لم تسمح حاليا الصين بان
تمارس القوه
لفرض وضع لتغيير الوضع الراهن وفردي واقع
جديد في منطقه في منطقه بحر شرق الصين في
شارع الى
الضغوط التي تقوم بها الصين
والقلق الذي تشعر بها اليابان من امكانيه
ان تقوم الصين بخطوه مفاجئه بمحاوله
كما قامت روسيا في اوكرانيا ايضا تحدث عن
تطوير كوريا الشماليه الصاروخيه وانواوي
وقال ان اليابان همم ستعارض اي خطوه تقوم
بها
زعزعته الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه ولكنه
في نفس الوقت الماده ااه يد المسالمه او
الصداقه نحو كوريا الشماليه وقال ان همم
وقال انه مستعده للقاء الزعيم بدون اي
شروط وحدد قضيه هي قضيه المختص يابانيين
المواطنين اليابانيين على يد كوريا
الشماليه الذين اختطفوا في سبعينيات
وثمانيات همم ارقام الماضي وقال انه سيبدر
كل ما بوسعيه لحد المشكله واعاده
المختطفين وجاء في سياق ذلك رغبته بلقاء
الزعيم لحل القضايا العالقه بين البلدين
وبطبع تطوير النوويه والصاروقي الذي يخلف
اليابان كثيرا وايضا تناول الخلاف مع
كوريا الجنوبيه وضروره في حل هذه المساله
ونقطع اخيره كانت تتعلق بتعزيزه تعاون
العسكري مع الولايات المتحده واعاده نشر
القوات الامريكيه في جزيره او في نوى
الجنوبيه اليابان